con cánticos palmas y ramas de olivo es
así como miles de feligreses cristianos
participan de esta procesión del domingo
de Ramos en Jerusalén la más auténtica
pues como narra los evangelios fue aquí
donde multitudes celebraron hace más de
2.000 años la entrada de Jesús a la
ciudad montado en un asno y aclamado
siendo El Mesías Cómo conectar contentos
cuando Cristo nos ha salvado cuando él
ha dado su vida por nosotros Entonces
esto es lo que estamos celebrando con
Las Palmas que él es el Señor y esta
procesión quiere recordar precisamente
ese momento de Jesús entrando a la
ciudad a Jerusalén que llega un momento
festivo para la época en el momento no
porque era el rey El rey de los judíos
El Rey de Israel ese rey del universo
rey de todo el mundo es por eso que
nosotros cantamos alabamos bailamos por
eso que entrando compañía con él también
entonces también entramos con ese gozo
no
con este júbilo que da inicio a la
semana
los feligreses emulan este recorrido de
Jesús durante dos horas descienden desde
la iglesia de bethwage en el Monte de
Los Olivos hasta la vía dolorosa una
experiencia que es una bendición para
peregrinos de todo el mundo estamos aquí
celebrando Jesús y el amor y la alegría
que Jesús nos trae y toda la O sea todos
los países y culturas que están aquí
Unidos y es solo una celebración de todo
es muy diferente a vivirlo en cualquier
otra parte del mundo es fantástico te
llena el espíritu el alma esa alegría es
increíble es increíble es increíble
tenéis que verlo
sin embargo este año no se puede obviar
que la festividad se da ante un aumento
de los ataques a la comunidad cristiana
que van desde destrucción de tumbas
agresiones físicas es por ello que en su
mensaje anual de pascua las iglesias de
Jerusalén pidieron las autoridades de
Israel no solo seguridad sino un acceso
libre a los actos religiosos cada vez
más restringidos